welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 77 this is my very
favorite format of episode opposing
views you hear views from both sides of
contentious issues and you can make your
own mind up
and this is an episode on covid
everything coved vaccines passports the
great reset it's intense
big news i was just re-monetized so
hopefully this episode doesn't
immediately get me demonetized again
i emailed 20 doctors to get views from
the mainstream medical community on
covet just like the normal people views
everyone said no except one guy one a
virologist so when you're listening to
the following conversations remember
this was the only guy that would agree
to be on this episode so kudos to him
first you're going to hear from dr joe
mercola he's an alternative medical
practitioner and he's recently released
a book called the truth about covert 19
exposing the great reset lockdowns
vaccine passports and the new normal
that's linked below
he has what's seen by the mainstream
media as the more conspiratorial view on
covid and vaccines the great reset etc
the second half of this episode is with
dr jeremy camille he's a virologist and
holds the more popular mainstream view
of kovid he did his post-doctoral
fellowships at cornell university and
harvard medical school and currently
works at louisiana state university
let me know what you guys think about
this episode please try to be polite
this is a super contentious subject and
finding guests was nearly impossible
please don't bully anyone or these
episodes will be even harder for me to
set up
be good
remember to hit subscribe if you enjoy
this content
this episode is brought to you by
self-authoring self-authoring was
developed by my dad over the last 30
years with help from two other phds at
mcgill and harvard
it has past authoring allowing you to
write out your past great for trying to
work through trauma i'd recommend
writing about trauma at minimum a year
after it's gone so you don't
re-traumatize yourself
it has present authoring which helps you
write out your present identify flaws
that you can work on figuring out and
future authoring which helps you make a
plan for the future with code mp you get
10 off at selfauthoring.com and it's a
great thing for people who are trying to
organize themselves i really believe in
it if you don't have a goal you have
nothing to aim for this helps fix that
that code also works at
understandmyself.com if you want to
check out your personality using a valid
personality scale enjoy this episode
[Music]
dr mccola welcome to my podcast well
such a pleasure michaela thanks for
everything you're doing and helping
promote uh health and wellness in this
area in this world because there's so
many people who don't get it and they
need the truth and knowledge so i really
i deeply appreciate your
passion and your commitment to helping
people understand health at a deep level
thank you thank you very much uh for for
anybody who doesn't know you
can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do
well i'm a formerly trained physician
for the since 1982 is when i graduate so
nearly
40 years now
and um
my foot my specialty is family medicine
i treated tens of thousands of patients
before i formally shifted out into
well i shifted into natural medicine in
the in the early 90s and then was able
to help lots of people and then
i am also passionate about tech so i
started in tech in the late 60s with my
first computer programming class
and it was an early adopter of the
internet in like the mid-90s and it
actually started my own website in 97
which is years before google and then
hopefully will become an important point
is later in our conversation but uh so i
predated google
and
um
i've had the most visited natural health
side in the world for except the last 17
years is be i think it might the
statistics might be changed it's really
hard to know now because of the
bastardization of the whole system and
and how you actually categorize and the
information started to get now and that
google is censoring essentially any
natural health sites so it's a confusing
state of affairs to say the least so we
don't really have accurate metrics now
but for the longest time we did i was
the most and i've got many new york
times best-selling books and
and i've got a new one coming out now
which is why we're talking this is going
to be another bestseller because amazon
has already pre-ordered a hundred
thousand copies of this book
they rarely rarely do that it's probably
only a handful of books that they do
this in a year so it's coming out at the
end of april it's called the truth about
covet 19 and hopefully we're going to
touch on some of those things today i'm
so excited to do this i found out about
you a long time ago when i was trying to
figure out what was going on with my
health and i went through your website
and i read some of your
kind of
science articles that are broken down so
anybody can read them
and i thought okay some of this makes
sense and then i did a background search
on you on google and you came up under
quack watch and i was like ah [ __ ] this
is just one of those guys that's selling
supplements and taking advantage of sick
people um because i'd been to a whole
bunch of naturopaths before and my mom
had spent hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of dollars on tests and
supplements and nothing had ever done
anything because i was so sick
so i totally brushed you off that was
when i would think it was like 18. and
then
i i did i did you know like five years
of research and tried to figure out what
was going on and when i was 24 i was
like are you kidding me
this guy actually knows what he's doing
that's crazy
but you are
very much on the alternative health
spectrum like i would say if there's an
if there's a spectrum and
you know microbiome experts are over
here you and and mainstream medicine is
like way out of the frame you're you're
you're almost out of the frame over here
i don't like to view it as alternative
because this really is the traditional
medicine is the medicine that our
ancient ancestors use and many still
ancient cultures still incorporate so we
just i i choose to believe that although
conventional medicine which is modern
medicine typically uh with antibiotics
and surgery i mean it can it's really
really useful for some limited
indications like mostly acute traumas uh
and you if you get in a car accident
you're going to want to go to a trauma
center you're not going to want to see a
natural medicine doctor until afterwards
and you recover from it but uh
there's indications for it but those
indications are pretty limited probably
far less than five percent of the health
challenges that we
encounter today
yeah
my um my decision for going to a doctor
uh is usually because i need some sort
of surgery right yeah that's like that's
my rule right now or if i pick up a
serious infection
yeah but in your case specifically my
heart bleeds for you because i've
treated thousands of patients with
rheumatoid arthritis and a few with jra
like you have
uh
and that was one of my first entries
into natural medicine and um
so if you need surgery for a joint
correction from the
jra
that's not really treating the problem
that's treating the symptom you know
it's a so they're never really hardly
ever addressing the cause of why you got
the rheumatoid arthritis in the first
place and we've had an offline
conversation about different things that
you do and i just commend you for your
it's so rare to find an individual like
you who just is so committed and
knowledgeable to searching for the truth
you are way less than five percent of
the population probably way less than
one percent you know i don't mean to put
you on a pedestal but you got to
recognize that you have a rare trait
and i it and hopefully people will
understand this and be inspired by your
actions to know they too
have the power to what we use as our
mantra is to take control of your health
which is what
the primary focus of what we're seeking
to share with individuals is they can do
it they don't need to rely on the
conventional medical system they can do
copy exactly your behavior and figure it
out for themselves and hopefully we're
there as a resource to help catalyze and
speed up that learning curve yes exactly
okay let's start off
by covering kovid
and the great reset which i really don't
know much about so let's start i think i
think let's start with covet and get
into that so is kovid a flu
well no it's not a flu it's clearly not
a flu i mean there's a lot of uh
controversy on this issue there's a
significant segment i've even the
natural medicine community or another
health community that believes it's not
even a virus that it's just a terrain
problem and i have problems with that
because it is clearly an infectious
disease i mean there's just no question
in my mind that is and to to argue that
it's not is just putting people down a
wrong unnecessary tantrums because
they're missing the big bigger picture
so it's it
i think there's more than enough
evidence to justice an infectious
disease it's a coronavirus as everyone
knows
now that not all the flu is actually is
influenza virus so it's a different
virus now the coronavirus can cause cold
like symptoms which is similar to the to
the flu but it's clearly a bit different
so it's a and there's other more serious
illnesses like mers middle eastern
respiratory virus and some other sars
cub one
that are previous serious corona virus
infections but for the most part it's
it's a it's a relative it's an what they
call a novel corona virus and novel
means new so it didn't really exist
before 2019 this variant of a
coronavirus so it's its own unique
system so it's clearly clearly appears
to be an infectious disease a new one
not previously identified there's an
other entire controversy on whether this
was
a natural outcome of breeding this in
bats or was leaked from a lab and i
think there's beyond beyond compelling
evidence now this coming i mean emerging
and we
documented this in february of 2020 that
it really was engineered in lab that
this is a no
yes this is get there's no there's no
that's a big part of the discussion of
the book there there's gain of function
research that was that was being
performed in the wuhan lab which is it's
a there's a specific labs and there's
china only has a few we have hundreds in
the united states of the they're called
bsl biosafe biosafety
levels
yes
i might be missing one of the letters in
about biosafety levels labs
i'm missing one letter i forget what it
is but the they're level four labs which
is the highest level that of isolation
and so that they don't get contaminated
uh but appears to be in
engineered created from scratch or
almost or take they've taken a rig
an existing coronavirus and and
introduced functions in it that make it
more more deadly and infectious
so there's it's not clear at all if it
was accidentally released or
intentionally released and i don't make
any
uh claims of to either but it does
appear to there's just such strong
evidence we don't have time to go into i
mean we can literally discuss it for
three hours and it's very compelling
i've written about it on my site i mean
you can get deep down into the weeds and
the on the hardcore science and the
muscular biological level to show that
it it clearly was engineered
wow
okay
okay i'm we're not going to get into it
but like a little bit into it why would
were they would they have just been
tested
like why
the u.s has funded this at the tune of
millions of dollars found she funded it
uh and then and and not just last year i
mean the research has been gone for a
long time the university of north
carolina ralph barrack is a big
coronavirus or coronavirus
researcher so the question is to why and
this is the justification and the excuse
they give is that well if someone else
does it then we have to be prepared to
defend ourselves so it's a defensive
strategy is the nuclear war type of
thing yeah so and but in the meantime
it's actually a form of bioware by
warfare and i've interviewed twice now
francis boyle who is an uh i think he
might be a professor emeritus at the
university of illinois and he's actually
responsible for one of the major
treaties he i think he drafted that in
the late 80s that would actually if if
someone is convicted of
this bio engaging in biowarfare
activities they have a lifetime
imprisonment i mean there's no
he he he's sort of a pacifist so he
excluded the death sentence in this but
definitely lifetime imprisonment and i
think many of these people should be in
prison lifetime for what they're doing
it's just
it's it's bio warfare is what they're
what they're creating and that's that's
against the law trees that have been
signed by virtually every country on the
planet
wow okay i wasn't expecting that yeah i
wasn't expecting that well it's not it's
it's kind of an interesting tangent
you know it's not the big part of the
story that's a relatively minor smart of
the story there's there's much more
points that i want people to understand
before we finish the conversation that's
that's like okay that's nice but that's
not the real deal there's there's much
uh
more points you need to take home before
we leave but plus it wouldn't really
matter right because it's already out
yeah it's already out it doesn't matter
and there's going to be another one i
mean they're very clear the
i don't know are you familiar with event
201 or 210 2 no 201 201 was no okay so
event 201 was held at johns hopkins in
maryland baltimore
uh six to eight weeks before covent 19.
six to eight weeks and what was it well
it was john hopkins it was the world
economic forum it was the bill melinda
gates foundation
and they all got together and they had
this trial run this exercise what would
happen if we got infected with
coronavirus infection and they ran
through the newscast and all the things
that they wanted to do and this it was a
trial run for cobit 19. that's really
triumphant they knew it was coming they
absolutely knew it was coming otherwise
why would they do it eight weeks before
so this is their pattern they broadcast
what they're doing they let the world
know
but not everyone knows even people like
you did who were pretty sharp and didn't
know that they did that so it's they
they leave these clues all around so
they're they're gonna there's gonna be
another one whether it's an infectious
or bioterrorism act
this is the strategy they're using
that's part of the larger picture which
is essentially so you know
i'm sure your primary question is why
are they doing this why could they
possibly want to do this right
with that how come people don't know
like if it was it well i don't know i'll
get into why they don't know that's a
great question
a lot more complex answer
why is the important one to understand
what is the motivation why would they
want to do this it's very simple and
this is part of the great recess which
is part of the world economic forum
which sponsors davos and it's klaus
schwab is the the guy you may have heard
about the guy looks like i'm james bond
villain and he probably is
but hey
he really ever seen him you ever see
clash schwab i'm telling you tell me it
doesn't look like a james bond
yeah you we should you should like
integrate a picture of him i will i will
yeah you should like gold figure whoever
maybe that's the wrong one but
he does look like a james phone film
yeah
yeah i told you it was pretty crazy so
yeah schwab
yeah so the uh
anyway their motivation
and really is part of the great reset
this this this move towards technocratic
global tyranny whose primary purpose
purpose is to transfer the vast majority
of the wealth and the assets from
everyone else to them it's a wealth
transfer move is what it is
and and they're you know it's an
exercise in implementing that strategy
and the
how they did it is a is a
much
more complex analysis and understanding
and requires you know a lot of
background to understand it but
essentially that's why the why it's been
done
and it's very clear and and if you look
at their literature i mean they've got
their videos and everything they let you
know they're not like hiding the fact
it's
it's in plain sight they're not trying
to hide it
and so that's what your book is about
does it just point out where all these
like hidden secrets are
well they're not hidden it's really in
plain sight it's just that people aren't
aware of it and they couldn't they don't
even believe it so why are they looking
for it and
told something completely well here
that's the key element told something
how are we
told something right that's that's the
key question we're told something
typically and in most
cases through the conventional
mainstream media
okay
so
gates is another player in here
the the that i failed to mention well i
did mention it was the bill melinda
gates foundation but what i didn't
mention is the world health organization
is the is really the the tool and the
resource that was was used to implement
this global shutdown and this
catastrophe that they just did in the
last year
so
it kind of because it's attained the
status of this recognized global
authority right so you got to wonder
who's behind the world health
organization trump and and
i don't take a political stance i'm not
pro-trump or anti-trump at all i'm
neutral okay because it's not about
politics
but trump
i think rightly
shut down the funding of the united
states from the world health
organization last year i don't know if
you know that but he did he shut it down
so when he did that the united states
was the primary funder of the world
health organization or who for short
and
when they when trump shut that support
down guess who was the biggest funder of
of the world health organization in the
world the biggest funder
gates yeah skates bill gates more than
any other country he was the number one
and he's very strategic bill gates is a
very very smart guy highly strategic but
he's part of the global tyranny effort
no question about it and he
over a decade ago embedded himself in
the world health organization and
essentially now i mean for the last
decade he's been making himself like a
vital part of the whole process so that
he can implement this strategy with his
which is this vaccine solution and
because that's the only thing that works
and i and you probably
kind of think about this
if
you know and we can go into vaccine i
mean i'm not an expert on it and i
haven't studied it deeply but i know the
i can know the broad strokes
so
if you believe the people who are
promoting and supporting this vaccine
are authentic and sincere and and
critically believe that it's going to
end this pandemic
then why and we're getting into some of
these other questions that you had
earlier
then
you would think they would allow free
discussion of the pros and cons because
there is no way in the world it is
physically impossible that you could
give an informed consent
to any therapeutic intervention unless
you know both sides if you're only told
one side how could it be informed
consent it can't be it's impossible
it's it's essentially propaganda and
that's what they've done
i think though yeah like
i
an alternative could be that
the people who are in charge who truly
believe the vaccine is the answer
believe that the general public are too
stupid to make their own decisions
and therefore aren't letting them make
their own decisions
think because they're doing it for their
greater good and they're right that
could be their
my guess is that's what they tell
themselves that's their justification
but if you let if you go higher and you
look at it objectively and it's hard to
look at this objectively because you
know there's so much emotion involved
but if you look at it objectively
you have to realize that you
it is as i said it's impossible to have
informed consent unless you understand
both sides and it's totally suppressed
it anything anything that even comes
close to hinting of casting the
disparaging vaccines and disparaging
life is immediately removed immediately
censored
entirely
whole platforms all many sites have been
taken down including bobby kennedy's
who's a you know he's pretty much
vaccine neutral i mean even though he
appears to be an anti-back person he's
if they work fine he he's vaccinated his
family he's not opposed to them but that
you've got to do with common sense
because
these companies these corporations these
multinational corporations that are
making these vaccines like pfizer being
the classic example and johnson johnson
they're criminal entities they've been
they've been convicted
of crimes in the past paid billions and
billions of dollars in fines for
breaking the law
so why
would anyone seriously consider trusting
these companies
when they have a history and the history
isn't good
i mean tens of billions of dollars in
fines have been paid by these companies
because they're they're criminals
so you know they've got a track record
and the track record isn't good
but
you know the fact that they're censoring
everything is is really a clue that you
know it it's part of the issue so the
world health
organization that countered the vaccine
as the final solution was censored
that goes down and this this is if you
just step back get
detached and try to be as objective and
non-emotional as you can
you have to understand that there's the
way a vaccine works the way any
intervention works is through your own
immune system and you deeply appreciate
and understand that it's your immune
system that does the work it's not a
magic pill or a magic shot that just
catalyzes your own and activates your
immune process so that you can
effectively defeat these pathogens
so but nothing nothing was done to
address that our own healthy immune
system so any therapeutic intervention
that was suggested as to being useful
was
censored taken off immediately what are
some of the primary examples like
vitamin d
i mean we have been exposed to the sun
ever since humans have been walking the
planet it's part of our natural system
to optimize our health and sadly our
vitamin d levels have just
dropped dramatically largely because
most of us live inside and many of us
don't even live in climates that we even
if we didn't live inside
or not go you know we don't even have
access to that amount sufficient amount
of sunlight to optimize the vitamin d
levels without taking a supplement i i
sell supplements but
you can absolutely be incredibly healthy
without ever taking these supplements
especially if you're wise enough to
follow carnivorous like you recommend
because there's such a nutrient-dense
diet
that
there's not a lot of supplements you're
going to need with that you know not
many maybe vitamin c but you know not
much because especially for eating organ
meat it's full full of vegetable almost
every mineral you can get
so
anyway they squashed all the vitamin d
information they squashed anything that
that that was natural and not only they
scratched natural therapy and by the way
i've neglected to mention that i
published a peer-reviewed
a study that was a review of
most all the literature that was
published prior to summer of 2020 and it
was published in a very prestigious
journal called nutrients and i had two
other co-authors in
and it was peer-reviewed and it was
published and it was october of 2020.
so that was the first article i
published this century i published like
20 last century but maybe 25. but you
know i just stopped doing it because i
had the website but i felt this is
important enough to do and we we
actually have a um i created another
website called stop
coveredcold.com stopcovetcold.com free
website is there's no you don't collect
your email or anything it just has you
can download pdfs you can take a quiz to
see how likely they are to get it uh so
they don't address vitamin d and they
don't
even believe
that
they acknowledge it if you're obese
that you're at higher risk i mean how
could they not deny that it's just as
the evidence as clear as can be and they
have these other comorbidities which are
like high blood pressure or
diabetes but the the central common
denominator throughout all those
diseases is the fact that they are
insulin resistance and another term for
insulin resistance as you well know is
called metabolic flexibility where your
body has the ability to seamlessly
transition between carbohydrates and
fats as your primary fuel and most
people in the united states
how many people what percentage of
population is metabolically flexible do
you think you probably know this you're
pretty sure i i don't think i i do know
i'd say 30 20. okay
yeah that that's an interesting and
pretty good uh answer for someone who's
as smart as you
but the actual answer is even more
surprising it's only ten percent
so even though obesity what's the
obesity rate
the obesity rate
well the obesity rate is about 40
depending which state you're in
uh but
being overweight is about overweight
yeah
so
being overweight is one characteristic
of someone's metabolism flexible the
other thing would be diabetes or high
blood pressure uh waist size
you know that's abnormal so
um
but it's about 90 percent of you so or
you know triglyceride hdly sure there's
a number of clinical variables that you
can use to make that assessment but it's
about close to 90 percent 90 and those
were actually stats from 2016 which was
the ending yeah
so wow
so there's
you know and that's that's at the core
that is the absolute core
of why people are succumbing to this
disease because they're metabolically
inflexible in their vitamin d
insufficient but even if you wanted to
take it a level above and you've got to
stay within the conventional medical
paradigm and use drugs which i'm not a
big fan of and use drugs to treat this
disease there were two drugs that were
absolutely vilified even though they've
been used for ages and are incredibly
safe you probably know what those are
hydroxychloroquine and ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine
used at the right dose and with zinc
early in the disease is highly highly
effective do i recommend it no i think
there's better strategies but if you're
going to go into conventional medicine
you want to do it's great oh the other
thing they abilify to is high dose
vitamin c
even though there's many experts within
the conventional medical community
they're experts in emergency medical
care and you know well-respected
professors at universities that uh paul
merrick m-a-r-i-k is a one that comes to
mind and he's published this sepsis
protocol which
incorporates intravenous vitamin c uh
thiamine vitamin b1 he's got the math
protocol and that's uh the m is
methylprednisolone which is a steroid
uh and the t is thyme and vitamin b1 and
the h is heparin because one of the
symptoms of cova 19 is this clotting
defect and disorder that causes
clots to occur so the heparin is an
anti-clotting factor and that kind of
helps the body a bit i think there's
better strategies that's for sepsis
for sepsis yeah and cover 19
the same sepsis protocol
which is is
it i forget the specific number i'm
sorry i didn't review this earlier but
it's a large number of people i think it
might be hundreds of thousands of people
here die from sepsis it's a large number
of people
but this iv protocol with the vitamin c
is highly effective i mean it's like an
80 effective rate very few interventions
are
100 percent although the nebulized
peroxisomes 170 000 americans die as a
result of sepsis per year well thank you
i wasn't too far off and i wanted to go
conservative rather than look hyperbolic
you know so it's 270 000 i was off but i
missed it by 70 000. that's a lot of
people that's a lot of people yeah
let me just comment on the number if
it's truly 270 000. and it probably is
there's no reason to doubt that
my guess
this is so interesting my guess is that
number exceeds the number of people who
died from covid
no no you're wrong 500 000 people died
from colvette
no did they or did they not
how did they diagnose that covet death
this is another thing we discussed in
the book
they used a test typically
the
pcr test polymer's chain reaction which
is a test that's designed to amplify or
increase in a cycle the amount of
material that they can use to analyze so
typically and every time is a cycle they
call a cycle threshold so the number of
amplifications ideally should be about
25 maybe 30 but they were doing cycle
applications of 40. so what's the
consequence of doing a real high cycle
threshold pcr test you're going to get
massively increase your false positives
so they're using a test that was
essentially bastardized and never used
the way it was designed to
and they falsely diagnosed people as
being positive when they weren't
that's the first mistake
and it was facilitated by the world
health experience they allowed it they
even though they knew better than that
and they subsequently reduced the cycle
thruster rate as soon as biden got
inaugurated they actually did it on
january 6. if you can believe it
so
they ratcheted it down right
but even assuming that that rate was
okay
i mean that that upgrade the test was
okay
and then truly there were 500 000 people
who had were positive copies and died
they changed the definition of the on
the death certificate so that if you you
had coveted 19
and you essentially died from anything
including a motorcycle accident
or you had terminal cancer and then
copenhagen your death was covered 19 100
why did they do that that's because
that's weird even for people who don't
believe these these they did that i can
i i'm highly confident i challenge
anyone to dispute that that statement
because it's true there's no question
about it and if you doubt that just look
at these numbers compare the total
amount of deaths
in 2019
to 2020.
if in fact 500 000
additional people died from covid we'd
have an increase of 500 000 deaths
how many additional deaths we have in
2020
zero
zero
zero michaela
no difference
all they did was reclassify those deaths
they reclassified did they did they
reclassify flu deaths because there are
zero cases of flu deaths that makes no
sense
absolutely every year 40 50 80 000
people die from flu no deaths in 2020.
no deaths from flu because they all die
yeah
no no no it's not because of messes
because they missed they misclassified
them there were flu deaths of course
there was no reason to believe that
there weren't any flu deaths i mean it
just somehow magically flew disappeared
and covered replace it yeah right that
this is totally a rational viewpoint no
no
there was zero flu deaths so
i i think or if it wasn't zero was close
to zero
it was close to the i think it was
i like i read somewhere on a government
website that it was zero and it was
somewhere in canada i think it's like
zero things yeah they just changed
things it's just crazy so but it's all
to support you know we got to go back to
what we talked about earlier what is
their goal why are they doing this
i mean because i mean even previously
there's no government in the world who
could have got to go away with this you
know there just isn't they don't have
the power the autonomy to do it but they
they use the justification of emergency
orders and that's a big challenge
there's a lot of legal challenges going
on because you know these governors of
these states declare emergency orders
and essentially have they're a total
dictator and autocrat they can do
whatever they want under justification
from its emergency order they lock
people in their houses they're into
prisons which has never ever been done
before in the history of the world to
lock in
healthy people it was only used
previously for people who were sick
they never locked in people who weren't
sick
but that's what and you don't you don't
think it's possible like my inclination
is to believe that most people are good
although i have come across some people
who are not good and that people are
scared
and stupid and that this is what happens
when
masses are being run by stupid scared
people
well i think that's true for the
majority of the population i would tend
to agree with that but
you know it's a bit too too uh
it's too weird no no it's the derogatory
acclaim because i think people are they
want to do well but they do they just
know the time effort energy to
understand
or the desire to go deep like you do
and as a result there's highly
susceptible to propaganda and
brainwashing it's a very effective
strategy a very highly effective
strategy and we didn't touch on this yet
but the whole issue is well how are they
figuring this thing out well one of the
biggest enemies in this that this is
stealth enemy that hardly anyone
appreciates or understands is google
they are
they are top on the list of technocrats
they blank that because this is going on
youtube
is bleeple
bleeple well i don't know that they're
that that was a joke yeah yeah yeah but
but yeah i don't know if that you do my
might censor this thing they i wouldn't
be surprised but anyway
i've already demonetized it's fine yeah
well they may de-platform you which is
even worse you know you're not don't you
lost your youtube channel so you can
it's nice to have you to jump because it
has such a wide range and that's going
to change in the future but anyway
google started as i said after my site
did and then when they first started
they were great i don't know if you were
online back in the late 1990s but they
were they were a miracle when because
all the other surgeons who were trash
and they were really really good and
they you know they then they just
progressively became more nefarious and
essentially they had to monetize their
site so they became very very good at
some developing the ability to predict
human behavior and the first way they
did this was google adwords so they
could
through all the data they were
collecting they knew what was going to
work and what didn't because they had
very sophisticated methods of analyzing
and sophisticated computer systems
and they could accurately predict you
know really really well what people
would click on what they wouldn't click
on so as a result of that predictive
behavior
they made a lot of money a lot of money
and they they kind of had to because
they were just providing all this
service they needed a source of revenue
and that was their way to do it but then
they just extended it and extended it
and they started capturing more and more
data to the point like they did them
between them and facebook they probably
captured the vast majority of
data that's captured and people use
their magnificent services they do
provide a lot of value but they do it at
price because people are surrendering
all their personal data without any idea
that that's what they're doing that's
the price they're paying for using these
services
and so google's collecting all this
information they know with a very
precise certainty exactly what triggers
will be required to change human
behavior and it's this information
that's shared with the mainstream media
because the mainstream media is
controlled by usually a few entities
that's all it takes and gates is one of
those entities
he's very cleverly invested significant
sums of money which is relatively small
compared to his net worth but i mean
this probably hundreds of million maybe
even less
to like the bbc and you know really big
media platforms
and so there they would never publish
anything uh that's
negative about gates they just wouldn't
and they'll only publish things to
support his position and then
uh
cooperate in the in their efforts to
censor and de-platform any any opposing
views so they've got control of the
media and they and they know exactly the
stories to run and the information to to
support because they've gathered the
data they know and and typically the the
data they've gathered is to support
the
creation of the most powerful emotion
that drives human behavior do you know
what that emotion is
fear yeah you guessed it you've nailed
it on the head it's exactly what it is
it's fear
and they drive they drove that to the
core they knew precisely
what story to tell
so effectively
that the vast majority
more than half of the population is
clamoring for the vaccine they want it
and they use another very effective
strategy that's that any any skilled
marketer would know you know what that
strategy is
something called scarcity
if you make something that you know
there's a lot of propaganda behind it so
that's going to solve the solution it's
going to make you immune and you make it
unavailable except to a few people
you're going to want it because you
can't get it you can't get it right
and that's what they did for three
months very few people get this vaccine
but it was only three months and that's
a relatively small amount of time 12
weeks right now anyone can get it
but they created this scarcity so
you were so lucky if you were able to
get it so everyone was clamoring to get
this vaccine and they only had one side
of the story no one told them about the
downsize or the potential downsides
you know what one of the biggest
potential downsides is
what
what do you think
of the vaccine
well my concern for a vaccine that
wouldn't be tested for very long would
be infertility
okay that's definitely happened i can
tell you a very specific mechanism how
that likely occurs but what's even a
bigger potential downside
especially for someone like you is young
and healthy and probably want to praise
the family but no it's death they die
okay
yeah yeah that's worse
yeah so
if someone's going to die from the
vaccine how will we know
i mean there's been some celebrities who
we know died from the vaccine like hank
aaron and there was
i forget his name but a very famous
boxer who died like within hours of
getting the vaccine but it's all denied
it was all hushed up and you know
covered over but
there are there's a there's a vaccine
registry called theirs the various
database
that is voluntary reporting
and as a result of the fact that it's
voluntary we know many studies have done
it says that the amount of vaccine
adverse reactions that are actually
reported are about one percent of the
actual number
okay one percent
so
how many deaths from vaccines have we
had this year
in the various databases you wouldn't
know i'll tell you
over 2 000 maybe 2 500.
that doesn't sound like a lot
but
let me tell you what it is
first of all if you just look at that
absolute number
it's more deaths
vaccine deaths in the first three months
of 2021 than the last 10 years combined
last 10 years come by
and
i already told you it's one percent so
2 2500
it's a quarter million people
a quarter million people and it's
first three months that's it
one percent
no one percent were reported
so
that means 99 were not reported so the
true number
is 100 times 2 000 or 2 500. gotcha
so now do we know that to for certainty
no it's just a guess it's a but we know
the numbers are a lot larger than
reported so maybe it's a hundred
thousand but it's still only three
months and they won't they've only given
what 50 million shots and they're
probably going to triple it or quadruple
it and and deaths continue to occur so
these are just people dropping dead in
the first few weeks right
um
so
my guess is that the vaccines will kill
more people in copenhagen
which is not hard to do because remember
500 000 people died well i already
explained earlier that it's a small
fraction of that who actually died from
copenhagen a small fraction so we may
have already exceeded the cover deaths
right now
that would be horrifying okay let me get
to a few questions okay sure um
what is an mrna vaccine and have we had
any other mrna vaccines great questions
had better tests on our longer tests on
do you know what mrna mrna is let to
explain i do but you should explain
anyway
so mrna is messenger rna
it's a complementary component to dna
and it's kind of like the reverse side
of it and
it's created from dna typically and it's
used to
send a signal it's kind of like the
blueprint that it gives to your protein
machinery creating machinery which is
transfer rna to create these protein
structures typically from amino acids
so
in the case of the messenger rna
copy 19 vaccines they created a copy or
a blueprint to create the
spike protein of the copen19
which appears to be the most immunogenic
portion of the of the coronavirus that
would tend to provide immunity
uh it's this mess this important thing
to know about messenger rna it's very
very fragile
which is why i'm sure you've heard and
most everyone has that they have to be
most of the fact that the first two
vaccines had to be
kept very cold i mean like like liquid
nitrogen cold
way below anything you can do at a
commercial freezer
regular one that you have in your home
so that's way too warm for it so it's
very perishable
and they had to protect it with a
liposome which is a fat droplet that
surrounds the messenger rna so that it
can be protected until it gets into the
body
so that liposome actually
allows it to not be digested by you
enzymes in your body which essentially
degrade messenger rna pretty quickly
because it doesn't stick around very
long it does it does its jobs and your
body gets rid of it but in the liposome
it could last a lot longer and jody
mycobits is a phd molecular biologist
and a nephrologist i suspect you've
heard of her before she's quite
controversial
and but she's really smart woman on this
and she believes that these messenger
rna liposomes can get into body tissues
and less for a long long time so what
does that mean if she's right
and we don't know i mean
yeah so you've got you've got
a signal a blueprint
telling your body to make the spike
protein
continuously
continuously
there's no they remember you know
i hate to make light of this but you
know there is
and i don't want to joke about because
you know with covert 19 jokes if i told
one 99.9 of the people wouldn't get it
right
oh my god that was terrible
yeah but but the a real joke is the mice
right
so
they they got this neural link
equivalent they were able to read the
minds of these these mice and what they
were talking about so they got this
conversation going and then one might
talk and the other says hey listen
you're going to get this coping 19
vaccine
and you know what the other mice said he
said hell no they're still testing it in
humans
[Laughter]
19 jokes
isn't it great you got to inject some
humors because it's just so
crazy you know what they're doing
you ha left is going to get you through
it so
but it brings to the emphasize a central
point which is why i've mentioned it is
because there's no safety testing on
this done they've done these adequate
tests i mean these these tests that are
very superficial very short term no
animal studies that normally takes 10 to
15 years to get the back normal vaccine
approved uh there were previous
coronavirus vaccines that were not
messenger rna they did them in ferrets
and they uh gave the ferrets the vaccine
and it worked great all the ferrets got
immunity to the coronavirus right almost
100 percent high antibody levels and
everything and then you know what they
did they exposed the ferrets to the
coronavirus you know what happened to
the ferrets
they all died
they all died
they all died
and and there was a mechanism for it uh
it actually has several names i like pie
which is paradoxical immune enhancement
but it's more typically called ade
that's terrible antibody dependent
enhancement
um so yeah it's terrible right so this
is this is the the kicker because all
these people are getting immunized well
some of them will drop dead and usually
the acute reactions are autoimmune
reactions typically catalyzed by
exposure to one of the
uh
materials they need to create the
liposome which is peg or polyethylene
glycol
and they have an acute reaction to it
and die that's is like a lot of peg i
thought peg was supposed to be safe
no no just pass through you no no no no
it's not especially when you inject it
no no oh my god no way okay he's not
safe so anyway that but that that's the
phase one phase two is that gets an
injection they develop this antibody
dependent enhancement
or pi paradoxical immune enhancement
paradoxical because the immune
enhancements is supposed to help help
you but in this case it kills you right
that's the paradox
so who knows what's going to happen to
everyone who was immunized when they do
get exposed to either coronal flu virus
or the covet 19. who knows we don't know
it's never tested it's never been tested
this is one of the greatest the largest
experiments in human history health
experiments
yeah and no one can scary
no one could deny it i don't care who
you have on to oppose these views no one
can deny that fact they can't there's no
okay
next question
this is this doesn't really have this
has something to do with what we were
talking about but how do you feel about
vaccine passports
oh my gosh that's that's a whole road
that is one of the initial
strategies they're using to for the
wealth transfer they're going to
identify it's in some ways it's similar
to what they did not to germany they're
identifying these people you know and
you're going to be they're going to say
you know they're going to get it where
everyone wants it and it's clamoring for
it they're creating this narrative in
this propaganda to convince people that
this is something they should they
should seek to have you know it's going
to because it's going to ease the
restrictions and all the benefits for it
when
actually it's going to be the one of the
worst things they can do that's what the
nazis did with the jews and
interestingly
uh this is an interesting aside that i
there's a division of ibm
in world war ii that worked with the
nazi germany to
implement the mechanization of this and
facilitate that from happening because
there's no way they could have done this
they needed a lot more sophisticated
system to do that and ibm helped them
and guess who's helping in the vaccine
papers for passports in the united
states in the 21st century ibm
aren't they right now i don't know if i
saw it in florida i think on somebody's
story that they were in a football
stadium and there was a section that
said vaccine people vaccinated people
only i don't i don't know those and i
doubt i don't recall seeing that
specific story i wouldn't be surprised
to find that but
what their goal and anticipation is and
this is what we need to stop
is they're going to if they're going to
segregate the people who have been
immunized and who have not so even
though these won't be required mandatory
vaccines literally that it's going to be
an effective mandatory vaccine because
you won't be able to travel won't be
able to go on a flight anywhere you
won't be able to go to a sports event to
a concert and eventually you won't even
be able to go into the grocery store
unless you got a vaccine passport
that's what they're doing they're
essentially making it virtually
impossible to live in a normal society
why would they want to do that to
everybody like
if this was if this was somebody's
master plan wouldn't they have
chosen certain people
or have they chosen just very few
certain people for for whatever reason
i'm still perplexed they have not
allowed me to sit in on their meetings
so i don't know i just don't know but
it's not a good strategy i mean you can
the evidence is clear historically when
these types of interventions have been
have been implemented it's just not a
good outcome
so we do not want this type of
identification system it's unnecessary
and it's all
done on the supposition that this
vaccine works and it's effective and it
prevents the disease and it doesn't it
does not prevent the disease all it was
proven in these fictitious studies
where
which do don't prove safety at all is
that it lessens the symptoms and i want
to get back to these studies because you
you were concerned about infertility
do you know that in all these studies
how many pregnant women did they test
how many
how many you can't test on none women
right none zero
no pregnant women i know and they're
giving it to pregnant women that's not
cool
like even if it ends up being safe you
should not that is reprehensibly
negligent malpractice yeah i agree
yeah and they're giving it to kids and
it you do you know the percentage of
children who die from kovid
oh god i don't know how many people
what's this right
many who percentage who don't it's like
99.99
it it's it's a very rare occurrence for
childhood diapers usually it's an
immunocompromised child or severely
metabolically flexible morbidly obese or
some other complication like um may have
had cystic fibrosis or something but
it's very very it almost never happens
and yet now they're encouraging kids to
get this vaccine i mean if
just
take the pieces of the puzzle the facts
that we know are indisputable
non-controversial and think put on the
thinking cap that god gave you and think
it through yourself and and stop
listening to propaganda you cannot if
you're rational you cannot come to any
other conclusion
you just can't
it's too obvious
okay next question
on a more positive note what should
people do what should people be doing uh
in regards to staying healthy against
covet love that i love to keep it
positive
as i alluded to this earlier you want to
be metabolically flexible and then so
how do you become metabolically flexible
there's several
powerful powerful interventions that
don't cost you anything the most
important one and the topic of a book
that i'm going to be publishing next
year
is is essentially to remove a very
specific fat it's an omega-6 fat it's
called linoleic acid have you ever heard
of that before
i have you happy you should explain yeah
but i definitely will explain so no it's
normally considered to be what's called
an essential fat meaning your body needs
because it can't make it but if you eat
food
if you eat food it's impossible to
become deficient in this fat because
it's almost in every food
you know the problem is we get too much
of it and so what's too much normally
our ancient ancestors got about to one
to two percent of the total calories of
their diet as linoleic acid
now it's like twenty thirty percent two
twenty to thirty times more it's crazy
so what's the what's the big deal well
it's a high it's called a pufa a
polyunsaturated fat acid
and it's highly susceptible to oxidation
which
is causes these damaging free radicals
which go on to damage your stem cells
cell membranes mitochondria
uh and as a result your energy's
producing structures become debilitated
or
just destroyed and it becomes very
difficult to function and and it will
radically increase your risk of every
single chronic deterioration of no
demand
heart disease cancer dementia diabetes
obesity
everything arthritis
so that is why you've got to limit so
how do you limit linoleic acid you
cannot have vegetable oils you have to
understand that a vegetable oil is a
metabolic poison the most pernicious
food toxin you could ever hope to
consume
it's got to be as close than gluten or
grains gluten looks like health food
compared to vegetable oil there's no
comparison now for some people it's
going to be a little bit worse
especially have really severe gluten
intolerance i don't recommend gluten but
i just want to give people a perspective
because they don't understand yet
virtually no natural health care
clinicians get this
they will
agree i mean really really sharp people
and i didn't understand until about a
year ago so i'm late to the to the table
to the party but um it's it's so crucial
to get this because the vegetable oil is
the thing that you've got to eliminate
so that means eliminate all processed
foods and i will i will debate anyone on
this anyone at any time because the
evidence is indisputable
and it just
makes me livid that this is not well
known but i'm i'm hoping to populate
this concept because that will radically
improve the health of the country so
you've got to limit you've got to
eliminate every vegetable oil you can
have none of them are good none of them
there is no excuse to have a vegetable
oil so that means that you have to look
at processed foods that means
eliminating most of your restaurant
visits because there's almost no
restaurant that doesn't use vegetable
oils
yeah all salads
they used to like i read that i think it
was mcdonald's they used to use i don't
know if it was lard it was some sort of
yeah yeah they use beef tallow typically
they use tallow that's crazy no that is
correct no and that is one of the
healthiest fats you can cook with is
beef towel especially from uh
organic grass-fed beef beef but even
regular kefo beef jello was still a lot
better
so and there is an organization that is
probably on the level of evil as evil as
monsanto or bill gates
it's called cspi which is an acronym for
center for science in the public
interest and they took out ads in the
late 80s and actually full-page agile
like usa today and
you know targeted mcdonald's and other
fast food restaurants about
using beef yellow because they they said
you're killing people and they convince
them to switch over to this vegetable
oil
they are responsible directly
responsible for killing tens prematurely
killing tens of millions of people tens
of millions of people
they're also responsible for leveling
criticism of me for bringing up the
things that i'm talking about and and
because of their encouragement and then
it did nothing happened in trump
administration because they wrote an
article that got us on the front page of
new york times in the washington post
and they were criticizing us for
for what we're saying and then they
encouraged the fda to write this letter
but they never did but as soon as the
moment literally a week after biden was
inaugurated then the fda wrote a
subordinating letter which had was 100
mirrorless
stands there's no way that it has any
merit at all it will be if it ever goes
accordingly similarly dismissed without
i mean that's it boom there's no trial
because there's no merit for it but
nevertheless they were able to do that
and you know they're
evidence it's this whole collusion
between this corporate
these multinational corporations and the
government it's it really is a fascist
fascist fascist passage
in in plain sight you know these
corporations are acting with the
government to deploy their their needs
so so it's happening but anyway cspi was
responsible for that transition
wow
yeah you did did you did you know that
no
i don't delve like i try and in order to
well you have done plenty good like a
great job with communicating with the
masses but in order to communicate in
the masses with mouses i'm trying to
stay like
middle zone
some people who make it hard i'm just
like oh that sounds like it could be
true but like
not yet
i won't delve into it yet um i'm trying
to grow first yeah i can't go off saying
yeah yeah no you're two boys i'll get
kicked off of youtube no i know you know
we've really grew we were the biggest
out there we're number one um so we've
you know we and people know knew about
it one of those tragic
tragic outcomes are results of this
implementation
is that people who know us it's not an
issue they can find us they can
subscribe to our daily newsletter for
free
and and they'll have the information
it's we're not taken off the internet
but we're essentially
for anyone new they'll never refine us
because we were moving the search engine
two years ago you would never find us
unless you knew someone that we were a
resource that was it
which is fine i mean we i mean we i've
i've helped hundreds of millions not
fine
rob wolf i heard even his website um oh
yeah there's dozens if not hundreds of
us have been taken off so anyone who's
telling the truth about this that
understands the reality of that it's
your immune system that works on this
and it's not this magic vaccine
uh they're going to be taken up there's
there's no question so
it's important to know i mean if you're
not involved in this and you might be
already know who these resources are if
you're watching michaela's channel but
if you aren't that there's a lot of
people out here know what they're doing
you're just not going to easily find
them but as soon as you find a few
the you know the breadcrumbs are auto up
to everyone else and you'll eventually
find the rest of the rest of us so
when texas and florida
they've been open
did their
hospitals ever overflow
it's the best of my knowledge they did
not i mean that was the justification
for implementing these shutdowns
and locking yeah
is that
we um what was the term they used
flattened the curve was it was the
collapse yeah yeah but that as soon as
they were able to implement the
lockdowns under the justification of
emergency measures
that term disappeared that term
disappeared and even using the
justification term that acknowledged
that they would never prevent the
infections they would just delay them
so that they
uh resources would be available to to
address the sick people so that they
wouldn't all come in at the same time
essentially
but they abandoned that now anyone no
one can get the disease if you got the
disease there's one too many
you know and so they've misclassified
people
and
it's just
it it's it's just absolutely surreal
it's like we were living in a dystopian
or uh george orwell movie you know
um yeah it does feel like that do you
know any of the statistics behind some
of the side effects of lockdowns like
increasingly
suicide delays
yet but i'm pretty confident that the
the
consequences of the the lockdown are
going to
exceed i mean even just the depression
the anxiety the suicides that it results
from this let alone the long-term
complications of
stopping
children
from going to school and having social
interactions
it's just so beyond crazy so i think
it's it's significant i just don't
recall the numbers and there's just so
much of information it's just hard to
keep track of all the details and this
is one i don't
know oh yeah well for sure i can just
ask you to bring up random statistics
but um i don't think some of the
statistics have been released like
because it's so early in the year i
think it takes a while for some things
to be released one of my main concerns
was
other than the increase in mental health
because i've suffered from mental health
issues but is delayed surgeries because
in canada we already have a long waiting
list and then there are like people who
really need help and their the hospital
section is closed down
and
it boggles my mind yeah you're already
compromised because the socialist
approach which and you can make i'm not
arguing for against it but you know
there are some downsides to it and then
you complicate it further with these
other restrictions and it just becomes
unbearable and people will die as a
result of that there's no question that
caused deaths it definitely caused
deaths
i mean just even the normal socialist
system i'd be not able to get a cat scan
or an mri scan for months you know and
that has consequences
yeah
okay um what would
say this it's what would a reasonable
response to this virus have been like
what should the government have done oh
that is so easy to answer that is so
easy it's exactly what we talked about
what can people do to protect themselves
and i didn't really finish answering the
question because it's so easy for me to
go on tangents on this so you have to
build up your i talked about vegetables
and then we would that we just tangered
in from there so you got one you want to
build up your they should have
encouraged strategies to improve the
person's immune system what are those
strategies improve your metabolic
flexibility eliminate all vegetables all
processed foods ma
optimize your vitamin d levels and we
had specific discussions on this because
that's a huge issue for your autoimmune
disease
so you have to have a healthy vitamin d
level if you live in canada there's
almost no one it's impossible to have a
healthy vitamin d level in canada unless
you're supplementing because you're just
too far north with home mandates stay at
home oh yeah yeah yeah it's just not
going to happen so you have to take a
supplement and you have to measure your
blood so what is the number the number
that you're looking for if this is your
u.s audience then it's 60 to 80
nanograms per ml that's the index that
their unit that they're using in canada
or in europe these are different unit
that's nanomoles per liter and that's a
hundred to 150 nanomoles per liter just
completely
cross out the normal reference range
because it's absolutely irrelevant they
don't know what the heck they're talking
about they're using ancient studies that
don't mean deadly squat if you want to
optimize your immune function at 60 to
80 nanograms per ml or 100 250 nanomoles
per liter that's what you shoot for
that's what you got to get typically the
average adult takes about 8 000 units a
day to get to that level assuming you
have no exposures right to the sunshine
now
you don't have to take vitamin d i
haven't taken vitamin d in 12 years my
level is 60 to 70 nanograms
so but you can get confused because you
were you were told me your level was 55
and then i said you know you live in
canada so you're using animals and
that's like less than 20 which is like
close to 20 it was like syrup you were
seriously deficient in vitamin d so and
you're so hopefully less deficient now
yeah yeah yeah well you're you're
heading there that's for you it's i mean
for all of us it's so important but but
for anyone with autoimmune disease it's
it's it's just one of the most important
uh therapeutic interventions you can
have and it's like almost free it's free
for me i've been taking it for 10 years
i just get it from the regular sun
that's it so it's where you're designed
to get it not everyone can do that as i
understand that most of us don't live in
the subtropics and have the freedom to
go out into the sunshine every day with
not much clothes on so although if you
don't do that you're not going to get it
from the sun
so the other thing so you really have to
go outside in a bathing suit to get it
from the sun properly yes yeah that
would be i like that description i never
said that i usually use longer more
complex terminology but i like it
because essentially that's what i do
recommend people do like in a woman it's
a you know a sports bra or a bathing
suit
that's the way that's exactly what you
need and it's got to be
during solar noon like in daylight
savings times that would be one o'clock
in non dollars daily same examples it's
12 o'clock
so um
so doing that
and then if you do get infected what the
most important strategy i would go to my
site at mercola.com mbrco1l8.com
and type in uh nebulized hydrogen
peroxide i've done
many interviews on it and and created a
specific interview that gives you
detailed instructions
on how to implement this because it uses
a nebulizer you have to doubles in the
details so you have to get a good
nebulizer because most of them are bad
they're inexpensive and they don't work
you get like it's only six or eighty
dollars is probably the best hundred
dollar investment you can make because
it will last for years and at the moment
you get sick you just use a very small
concentration because normally the
peroxide in your drugstore is like three
percent these this you would use a 0.1
percent so it's like 30 times diluted
and you dilute it with normal saline
which is a saltwater solution and all
the instructions on how to do it are in
there and if you do that you do like
every hour while you're sick
it's like incredibly effective it's like
well over 90 maybe beyond 95 effective i
mean it's the craziest
strategy and it's and after you've made
the investment for the nebulizer the
peroxide is free i mean
the dose that you're going to use is
less than a penny it's like less than a
tenth of a penny that's how much
peroxide you're using so
you know and anyone can use it and you
just inhale it and breathe it in for a
few minutes and and almost everyone the
cough disappears the fever gets better
the the feeling that they're going to
die just is gone i mean what i've so
many of my the friends and relatives i
know to use this and it's exactly the
experience they get and david bronstein
oh yeah it's everyone should have this
there's probably a justification used at
least once or twice a week to improve
your microbiome independent of that
so
yeah i don't know if you if this is
going to be a video if you're going to
article that goes with it but you can
put the links to the to the video or
subscribe that would help a lot of
people out and they can see i can do
that i go through 15 or 20 minutes i
explain the reason why peroxide works
and justification for it and more
importantly walk you through how to
create the solution because you've got
to have it in your home if you don't if
you don't have it in your home it's not
going to work but there's a benefit to
even doing it twice a week even if you
don't have covert or flu or anything but
boy if you've got a flu the moment you
have a sniffle or a sneeze or a cough
boom you do this and literally once or
twice and it's gone it is gone it's
crazy and there's virtually no side
effects if you do it properly you know
very low concentration
there's no side effects it's almost it's
almost free and it works i mean what
better what better prescription because
if if they had a magic
um
drug that you take this pill and you're
better well they have to make it and you
know almost every pharmaceutical has
side effects and there's a cost to it
they couldn't make it fast enough they'd
have to create hundreds of millions of
doses but
all you need is a nebulizer all you need
is nebula and peroxide which is there's
more than a peroxide to treat the entire
population of the world
um so it's an effective intervention it
works so those are the strategies
because i'm all this is answering your
new question which i thought was
brilliant is what can the average person
do
what or what should the government have
done to do that this is the same thing
the government should have courage these
structures and interventions because
that that would have reduced the death
rate from covid
um uh 50 is brain dead i was probably
somewhere between 70 to 90 percent
70 90 percent
yeah
okay dr mercola i'm out of time
okay is it is there anything else you
want to add no get the book you get the
book yeah coping 19. i mean okay where
can people find you
yeah welcome people
calm down
clla.com so you know you will not find
me in google
you won't find me on you i think we have
a youtube channel but you know anything
important we can't put on there so
but uh yeah it's been great i i just
uh cherish the time to with you and
the opportunity to
help you with your own issues because
you know you're just
i i just love people like you who get it
and have the
mental tenacity to go and research it
yourself and take control of your health
because you can do it you're such an
inspiration as everyone out there so
thanks for what you do
thank you very much
i appreciate it
[Music]
dr camille welcome to my podcast
nice to be here thanks for having me on
this is going to be a big episode we're
discussing all things covid and we have
two points of view here so
here we go
question number one
is covet a flu
is a dog a bird
no it's totally different viruses
okay here's a question then how why are
there no flu
cases anymore that's that's because
masks are really effective suppressing
viral transmission and the social
distancing that was enforced on the
australia we knew this was going to be a
mild flu year for us when we saw
australia because they get the flu six
months before we do their winter is
upside down relative to ours um that's
why you can like ski in the southern
hemisphere during uh some with summer
here um
so when you wear masks and people don't
gather indoors flu doesn't spread well
either so it's historically low it's
pretty amazing it shows you that there's
what they're called non-pharmaceutical
interventions they really were
to me who knows really nothing about
this it looks like
flu
flu cases could have been miscategorized
as covid cases like canada i think had
zero cases it seems unbelievable
zero cases there's no way that that's
possible yeah yeah i think there's
probably cases i mean every time the
government counts something it's always
under counting it almost almost always
because people don't go to
hospitalizations yeah i mean you have to
have like some big corporation do a swab
and register a test with the government
bureaucracy for it to exist in a case
number a lot of times you get a fever
and if you just feel better taking some
motrin or hanging out at home resting
you don't necessarily get a test there's
no official result of your fleet case
there's definitely flu cases but they're
they're down like i think like
well over tenfold uh perhaps even more
than that this year it's it's a tiny
amount of cases
okay before we get into it can you give
a brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
yeah so i'm first of all my name is
jeremy camille i have studied uh what
herpes virus is really for the last 20
years i'm not a coronavis i'm not a
medical doctor i don't prescribe drugs i
don't treat disease don't take anything
i say as medical advice but i do know a
lot about viruses and how they enter
cells because i've studied that you know
it's one of my passions is studying how
viruses work we rip out a gene and put
like a green gene from a jellyfish in it
to see like make the cells glow and
understand where viral protein does how
it escapes from the immune system that
kind of super nerd stuff that most of
the time people don't pay attention to
but then all of a sudden they pan down
and they're like oh your job's useful
again go help us um so
they shut down our campus
and told us we couldn't work on any of
the viruses that we were funded by the
nih or the you know the government to
work on for our research we compete for
grants and they said the only thing
you're allowed to do on campus right now
is help set up a covenant testing
facility and so
that's how i started working on kovid19
because it's not research it's like
trying to respond to a public health
emergency
wow so they turned to everybody's
research towards the pandemic at least
for a few months the first like during
the shutdown it was you stay home or and
if you're coming to campus if we if
you're caught just for liability issues
like because everything was closed if
you weren't like treating patients or
involved in like ramping up testing
because you realize the government
totally failed us on testing they didn't
have any tests ready and the test they
tried to roll it didn't work so we were
asked by the governor of louisiana and
state senator bill cassidy and our and
in turn our chancellor hey can you help
out can you guys set up a test and we're
like yeah i mean the technology to do
this pcr test is something that you know
if you have even a high school
level understanding of biology it's not
that complicated and i'm a big believer
for actually personally in that that the
average person in the public should be
fully in charge of their health and
empowered to understand how things in
medicine work um and so you know just
that's my belief for everyone you treat
everyone like intellectual equal
no matter where their background is and
um
so i thought well of course we can do
this this isn't like that magical but it
does have to be emergency authorized by
the fda and as a scientist you want to
look at what's worked for other
scientists and scientists tend to be
very transparent about their methods you
have to publish what primers you used
and how you did the assay and so we you
know developed an assay that was you
know we didn't invent new primers we
tested the ones that other people were
using and started a test and then then
from that it evolved to well it'd be
nice to sequence the whole genome
because you can now do really amazing
things to trace how the virus is moving
almost like a csi crime set you know
like if there's like if the murder at
least blood of the crime scene you can
figure out who his grandma was
because based on the the dna sequence
and so we're using those things to trace
the pandemic and watch how it evolves
and then um we developed we implemented
an antibody test invented by a group at
mount sinai uh new york in new york city
um a guy named florian cromer so we
could test people's blood to see who had
been infected yet because a lot of
people get infected and have very mild
symptoms if any and so you need to know
who's immune and who's not just to
understand basic things
and then we uh built a new assay
uh together
mostly invented by a guy named ben
hurley at icon mount sinai
um slow medicine new york again a close
collaborator of mine it's like a green
virus that has a spike on it but it's
like a safer virus we just basically
took the spike protein gene out of the
coronavirus and he put it in a
relatively harmless virus that glows
green and so now we can test people's
blood for whether their antibodies
neutralize infection and we recently got
trolled by the sputnik 5 the russian
vaccine
company on twitter because we published
some serum from collaborator in
argentina who could people who had been
fully immunized against sputnik
to no surprise those that immunization
was not that effective against the b1351
variant that emerged in south africa
and so they weren't happy that we shared
that information even though it wasn't
really a surprise a lot of the major
vaccines are to a large degree escaped
by the mutations on spike so it's
evolved from like testing for
coronavirus to limit cases and nursing
homes because in those places like one
out of eight people were dying or more
and so i mean those are old people some
people say oh well they're forgotten
they're too old they need to die anyway
i think that's what's the usual
what's the usual
uh death rate for flus in nursing homes
i think it depends from year to year
what the flu is but those are more
vulnerable people for sure if you're in
your 80s and you get a flu infection
depending on the year there can be mild
ones and more nasty ones
you're more vulnerable but i don't want
to
make people think that these viruses are
only dangerous to elderly people
being healthy jogging having a great
diet is not an insurance policy against
something like ebola loss of fever virus
or even a flu like the 1918 uh 1919 flu
that flu killed people in their 20s what
about
what about covet though kovid
is definitely more dangerous for you as
you get above 40 especially if you're
overweight
or have high blood pressure or
pre-existing condition but there's also
college athletes who got what they
thought was a mild case of coping and
then six months later they're still
suffering random like headaches uh even
psychiatric disturbances this is a weird
virus it does weird things that are
unpredictable some kids very young kids
most kids are it's like one in ten
thousand as a child if you're exposed to
the virus that you would die from it but
a reasonable if you're the mother of a
child who ends up with multi-system
inflammatory disease from a cobit you're
not too stoked to hear you know these
people telling you about how it's
harmless to kids um
this virus killed a a guy who was not
overweight
was the newly elected state uh sorry a
congressman to the to the u.s federal
congress he was about to be inaugurated
i think on january third or something of
this year and on december 29th he died
in our hospital just like you know
several hundred yards to the left of me
uh he was he was medevaced in from
monroe louisiana his name is luke letlow
he left he left behind two young
children and a wife who's now uh was
elected to his seat in congress but he
was in his ear he was 41 years old and
he died from covet 19 on december 29th
right here
so it's it's very we don't we scientists
do not completely understand why certain
people get fatally ill and others don't
but you're talking about a virus that if
you let it go unrep if you let it rip
and have people at bars and karaoke it's
not just your infection risk if you get
a whopping dose like if someone breathes
a ton of it on you and you aren't
worried at all you're not masking and
you're not defending yourself
i mean you're giving the virus like a
four-lane superhighway to zoom right to
your deep in your lungs and cause a lot
of problems and so it's definitely a
serious risk for people um even my age
you know and like
it's just funny hearing some of the
discussion on twitter or social media
people like pretending the virus doesn't
exist or it's not a threat at all like
you see a lot of people change their
mind or you see a post about someone who
thought that way and then they died and
you know that's no one deserves that
even if you're you don't deserve to die
just because you're wrong this is one of
those situations where it shouldn't be a
political thing at all we should all be
basically getting the real facts in our
communities not just from like tony
fauci or some federal authority we
should be talking to the people who
treat cases in our communities who we
actually trust and who you know who
aren't you don't have an agenda like the
only agenda should be truth like
transparency and truth
i completely agree okay i'm gonna run
through some questions sure where i'm
from uh in ontario
it's completely under lockdown and they
closed down schools and there's a
stay-at-home mandate right now
it's one of the strictest lockdowns in
north america
and then there are places like texas
that are open
so
in your opinion what kind of response is
the proper response to this kind of
pandemic
well i think it has to be driven by case
numbers and by what's safe and what's
not safe in the beginning of the
pandemic we didn't really understand
enough about how it spread so the
guidance was like you if you remember
like wash your hands it's so important
and like the playgrounds were like taped
off like they were crime scenes turns
out the virus does not spread
efficiently outside at all um it can
happen if you're like up close to close
to someone or if you're in like a dense
like if you're like a stadium sporting
events and everyone's screaming and
howling this this stuff spreads by
droplets and where people are crowded
with poor ventilation so i think bets
are off about like no in the indoor
outdoor transmission risk is very very
low i'm not going to say it's zero but
relatively speaking if you're like if
you're gonna spend your effort wisely
like we're like it's a hassle to wear a
mask all again some people get used to
it and i have friends and colleagues who
like wear it all day because they work
at like harvard medical school and the
policies are so strict there that
they're just like used to wearing a mask
at 95 all day um myself i like to take
it off when i'm walking outside so
what's some it's a reasonable um what's
a reasonable response should be driven
by the case number in your area if the
case number in your area is reasonably
low and the public health messaging is
accurate and people are doing the right
things like they aren't ignoring the um
guidance then the case numbers will stay
low enough and we can keep businesses
open and do stuff responsibly but when
when there's a new virus out there like
b117 this variant that is about 50
percent more deadly and about um
60 more transmissible like relatively um
that virus spreads a lot better and it's
actually spreading better in children
than than
original virus so the virus is evolving
as it infects us and the reason it's
evolving is because the pandemic's not
under control so it's all these ironic
things like a rich person can afford to
spend more but if you spend all your
money all of a sudden you don't have any
money to spend so if you're too careful
with the public health response then you
know you're going to control the cases
and that's a good thing
but you're going to like lose public
support
but vice versa if you leave if a leader
is like oh i don't care at all or just
every business should be open because
it's too much risk for the economy and
case numbers explode and hospitals are
really crowded and overflowing which
which happened in texas this summer i
mean we stayed at a motel on the way to
colorado to visit my uh
to visit my to get together with my
family member we all got tests my
parents like i have young kids and these
are their grandparents so we all got
tested and we we joined together and got
you know in colorado um but on the way
there you know some some of the motels
were
booked with er nurses like they're that
they were like traveling nurses who who
like there were so many of them that are
treating covet patients that there
weren't even
were the hospitals in texas ever
overflowing like did they ever turn away
patients this absolutely happened in
certain parts of southern texas and and
i'm guessing amarillo as well um it's
well documented they were they were
overflowing patients to a pediatric
hospital adult patients were going to a
children's hospital because there
weren't beds left in in the houston area
i think that that got bad around this
this winter was the worst like january
was really the peak of where hospital
systems you saw them getting strained
did that happen in florida too
i don't you know i don't keep track of
all all the stuff like i'm not the
world's encyclopedia on
all the things that happened i would
love to have that data for you i do
think there was strain on the hospital
systems from what i understand i don't
know if florida specifically overflowed
it's funny because ontario so i as a kid
i was really sick and i was in emergency
like
literally every four months and we i was
always treated in the hall because it
was always completely full wow and in
last last january ontario came out with
this or toronto came out with this um
article and it was like hospitals are
hospital ers
are at 86 capacity right and this was in
january and then in march april may and
then in december something came out and
it was like 87
hospitals are overflowing and it had
changed by 3 percent but the public
health
officials had switched it into
you know now it's a problem even though
it had been a problem before so it's
hard for me to
especially in ontario it's hard for me
to understand why you would close things
down because of the okay okay anyway
yeah you're right let's let's skip
i mean i wish say the one thing i would
say though is talk to the people working
in the hospitals like the infectious the
respiratory therapists the nurses who
take care of sick people because it's
not all about beds it's like how tired
is the person taking care of the patient
if they're working like 16 extra shifts
and not getting any sleep because
there's so many patients it doesn't
matter how many ventilators there are if
you don't have people to run them like
so i would just like reach out to your
canadian public health community and be
like hey what's the scuttlebutt like
what's really like you know because
those people i find are really honest
like they're brutally honest when they
disagree with like a math mandate
they'll tell you they're like oh this is
kind of this is silly the cases aren't
that bad or they'll be like oh my gosh
this is really terrible i wish more
people wore their mask because they're
the ones taking care of sick people that
i think you can trust them
yeah that's fair that's fair
uh okay okay next question this is a
good one so the more right-wing view at
the moment uh for whatever reason is
that the dangers of lockdowns uh vastly
outweigh the dangers of covid that's why
places like texas are open and florida's
open and you know new york's shut down
so their view is you know increase in
suicide delayed surgeries
vastly i would say outweighs the dangers
of covid
it's funny because in your opinion well
all i know is there's a really cool
article that just came out in one of the
lancet journals um and it was based on
data in massachusetts i used to live in
massachusetts there's a lot of depressed
people there trust me it's like high
stress especially in boston suicide
rates were lower this year this like
during the pandemic than they were the
year before by a little bit really yeah
i mean i wouldn't say it's like
statistically significant because you
have to like you know
it's not higher no not at all it's lower
so and they have like they're charting
it over over many years i even have like
the graph somewhere i printed it out
because i've got a kick out of that it
came across my screen on
on twitter i was like well that's funny
because i've heard that argument a lot
of times too that's what i mean
yeah
i mean i think it is a bummer to have a
lockdown but again
it's one of those things that if we did
a better job controlling the pandemic
and all agreeing on what the threat is
instead of dividing against ourselves
politically and deciding that oh the
virus is a myth or it's too small and it
can get through a mask and like not even
agreeing about basic things because
we're getting divided and conquered by
people who want to divide and conquer us
and we aren't like focused on the truth
and getting along as like a community
and when people can't agree and you have
like a zombie you know biting people
like if we were like in a zombie movie
you didn't believe in zombies like you
know it's not such a surprise that the
zombie apocalypse gets out of control
this is an invisible enemy it's a virus
and we can't even agree about germ
theory i mean this is like
scientifically settled stuff from like
you know hundreds of years now but you
have people effectively you know scaring
each other or hawking like homeopathic
cures that absolutely don't work and
there's no basis for them but they want
to sell you products and they want to
like you know and then you have the
government on their side wanting to
strip mine the genetic data of the
coronavirus and dump it into like
databases and like not empower your
communities so scientists like don't all
agree with each other we disagree with
each other all the time it's not like
science versus non-science it's just
like what's the truth what's really
happening and who can you trust
yes definitely i think the reason a
zombie apocalypse would get out of
control though is because one bite just
kills you that's true that's probably a
good point or you'll turn you into okay
turns you into a zombie that's true
kills you and then turns don't you don't
die before you're a zombie you're the
undead technically like a vampire that's
my like secret research project you're
not gonna talk about that right now okay
uh
okay do you know anything about this the
great reset
i i looked it up because you you said
something about it it's like something
from the global economic forum
or something like that am i right or the
world economic forum i've never heard of
it until you do you want to tell me
about it so you can educate me
no that's okay we'll skip that question
okay okay what about this question um so
another view that's out there is that
this is a plan for the elite to take
over given how hard this has been on
poor people and jobs that we're getting
forced into vaccinations it's being run
by the government the pharmaceutical and
the elite it's making the rich richer
it's taking away our freedoms if we
don't get the vaccine how do you feel
about that theory well i think that's a
pretty bad theory because the poor are
suffering the most from the virus if you
are a person who lives in a crowded
house who cannot socially distance i
mean the people are getting crushed by
this are prisoners who don't have access
to vaccines um people who have to show
up at their job as a bus driver
regardless i mean those people
um want the vaccine as as much or more
than the rich but you see the rich kind
of cutting in line trying to get it
faster because no one wants to get sick
i mean even trump apparently got the
vaccine on the dl like he didn't
announce it he went and got like
inoculated you know it's like you want
to be protected i mean remember the
thing about vaccines is that they allow
you like you you can teach a man to fish
but you know if if it or you can give
him fish if if you can fish for yourself
you're gonna be able to eat many meals
and i don't have to like catch your fish
for you your immune system is a great a
great uh
uh
complex beautiful like symphony
orchestra of evolution that defends your
body against all kinds of things like
it's like got a cia an fbi beat cops
it's got a whole bunch of different
cells that do different jobs and a
vaccine just gives it a mug shot of hey
here's the bad guy look out for this
dude and so it can make its own cells to
fight it so you don't need a
pharmaceutical company giving you
recombinant antibodies in a hospital bed
and billing you you know thousands and
thousands of dollars like a vaccine
enables your body's own native
intelligence to fight diseases the same
way you would fight the diseases if you
were naturally infected and came up with
the best immune response because immune
responses are very different from person
to person but a vaccine a good one
gets the most effective vaccine response
from the most people it mimics what you
would the protection you get from
catching like natural measles and
getting better from it without risking
like one in a thousand rate of fatal
pneumonia from measles which happens or
or women will lose their baby
prematurely if they happen to catch
measles while they're pregnant so those
are terrible outcomes and if you're
talking to four or five friends it
doesn't seem like a risk that any of you
are going to die from that you're like
what a thousand that's nothing but if
you like if you live in a city of
millions you start to know people who
died like and and and if it's a
preventable death it's kind of a sad
thing like why would you not want to
protect yourself like it's just yeah
i i i get that um people are concerned
right now that this
mrna vaccine is new that it wasn't
tested for very long
um
and that there might be side effects we
don't know of because the testing phase
wasn't very long and that if you're
young and healthy and your chances of
getting bad
covet or statistically aren't bad then
why should they get the vaccine
have there been other
mrna vaccines that
are common or that we've used to see
what the long-term effects are as far as
i know this is the very first mrna
vaccine in people but let me demystify
why mrna vaccines are so
from a regulatory standpoint which means
and the reason those regulations like
the fda is one of the best organizations
like as far as protecting your health
and watching out for like americans like
they are very very conservative about
what they will approve for use in humans
um so much so that the big pharma
companies aren't universally happy about
it you know but they they do have to
play by the rules to get their vaccines
and their diagnostic tests and any
therapy
approved so this this vaccine is
emergency youth authorized it's not a
formally approved therapy or a vac it's
not really a therapy it's a vaccine okay
um
the thing to know is that mrna is um
something that our cells make all the
time to it's like it's your ram if
you're a computer if you're new if your
dna code or your genetic code is your uh
hard drive
the the rna that's translated is like
the temporary message and so rna always
breaks down it's not there forever but
it can tell your little you have little
machines in your cells every single one
of your living cells has little machines
in it called ribosomes that translate
the genetic code and what viruses do is
hijack them they take over the cell and
they turn it into a virus factory this
this rna is basically looks a lot like
the rna our own cells make and what's
exciting about it is it doesn't have
much else in it so there's just the way
to get it across the cell membrane it's
called a lipid nanoparticle it's
basically thing that's stuff that looks
like stuff that already is around our
cells and bodies but it gets the message
across the membrane and makes just one
viral protein so it's so simple from a
regulatory standpoint they do have to
test it and make sure it's safe but when
you take a lot of other vaccines they're
much more complicated they have like a
replicating virus in them that's
weakened in passage in cell culture it
has a whole bunch of viral proteins it's
making and it was like grown in cells
which you know maybe were made like
people object to some of these cells
because they were made in 1970s from
like an aborted uh fetus or something uh
or a cancer cell line or something that
or a chicken embryo and people are kind
of freaked out by that this mrna is just
purely made from the same biochemicals
that make up our bodies like it's it's
our own genetic code just like the virus
does use our genetic code against us the
the mrna flips on the virus and and says
okay cool we're just going to take out
the one thing that we need to defend our
body to know about to defend our bodies
from covet 19 and we're going to give
you the secret message of what you need
to know here's the mug shot of the bad
guy in mrna form it's going to
self-destruct after it makes like a few
copies of this protein and then your
little like your immune cells are like
dude this guy looks weird and there and
they're going to grab the the cell that
is expressing the weird protein that's
from this virus that came from the mrna
and they're going to take a little
fragments of that you know dying little
cell in your arm and bring it to a lymph
node which is basically like the cia
station of your immune system and
they're going to compare notes and look
at it and then they'll make a whole
bunch of custom cells so instead of
needing like regeneron to sell you a
multi-thousand dollar antibody infusion
you'll know how to make your own and
you'll make these amazing like
antibodies shields in your mouth and
your nose that that when the virus like
if someone breathes on you and you get
covered in your nose you won't even know
it because it's blocked before it can
even get into your cell and that's an
amazing thing so they had already been
working on mrna vaccines for a long time
so they had a lot of other ones in
trials so they already had a pretty
strong safety signature but that's not
enough for the fda they needed to see
a lot of data from patients so the so a
number of companies got bankrolled a lot
by taxpayers pfizer went their own way
and bankrolled it themselves but they
they tested on like 30 000 people and
they had to ship they had to record
every single adverse event if i got hit
by a car after getting the vaccine
that's still recorded as an adverse
effect
adverse reaction and they have to vet
that hey did this car somehow hit them
because of the vaccine and if the
doctors have to go look at the facts and
be like no looks like you know a truck
hit the guy crossing the street had
nothing to do with the vaccine or the
person you know had a heart attack they
have to go look did the vaccine have
anything to do with that um yes or no
and they recorded every single thing
that happened to thousands of people and
they they determined that this vaccine
is extremely safe and and not only that
they were able to test that it's really
really effective ironically because the
pandemic was so poorly controlled um
they were able to find out it was safe
faster because so many of the people in
the in the group that didn't get the
vaccine came down with kovid and at day
12 post post inoculation of the first
shot you saw the curve separate like
that and it was just it's like it was it
just crushed the ability of this virus
to make you sick it and if you look in
like south africa like there's a lot of
like poor people in africa who don't
have access to the vaccine and even the
health care workers don't have access to
it and you saw that the few people who
were in these trials were really
protected from hospitalizations and
deaths yet us rich countries like europe
and the us are hoarding the really good
vaccines while like people in lower and
middle income countries are having to
wait or maybe buy ones that are a little
bit like not as well proven as the the
best ones we have access to here in the
us so i think the wrong conversation is
like oh should we trust the vaccine
you should you should find data on your
own from reputable sources don't like
don't don't get data from someone trying
to sell you something if someone's like
selling a health supplement online or
has something they're profiting from
don't look to them for information look
to people who aren't like making a buck
off of it and talk to medical
professionals like talk to the ones who
actually study infectious diseases don't
talk to an eye doctor to find out about
a vaccine against a respiratory virus
that person it's like it's like talking
to someone who fixes like uh
tvs and asking them like hey what's
what's up with my car why is it broken
like that's the wrong expertise
okay that was actually a really good
explanation of an mrna vaccine so thank
you uh to play devil's advocate here
sure
are aren't the um aren't the
pharmaceutical companies making money
each time somebody's vaccinated
um yeah they have giant contracts but
like you know i hope you're making a
buck filming this show i mean we all got
to feed our kids like if you want
someone to do something like that
yeah i mean like taylor swift probably
doesn't show up on stage and sing a song
like completely for free unless it's a
charity gig um the people i know who
made the vaccines like i i'm i
personally know uh one of the people who
invented the locked spike protein he's
at university of texas at austin his
name's jason mclellan and it's really
cool like he and another guy named
barney frank who's like all about giving
like young people um especially from
diverse backgrounds like literally like
leadership roles in science like like
empowering like young black women to
have just as important a job as tony
fauci it's like one of the best most
generous like oriented to like what's
good for people and trying to help and
give people the truth and figure out how
to protect human health they figure out
how to lock the spike protein in the
configuration that it needs to be in to
do its job it's like a spring-loaded
thing that pulls the virus into your
cells like a harpoon almost it like
fuses the viral membrane with your cell
membrane and then releases that rogue
genetic code of the virus that turns
your cell into a virus factory and you
don't want your cell to be a virus
factory trust me um
so they lock the fusion protein and the
pre-fusion conformer that's what it's
called and that's the one that you want
antibodies against that works it's
almost like if you were trying to
protect a mouse from a mouse trap like a
mousetrap goes you know like that and if
you were to make antibodies to lock the
you know if if the mouse traps in the
closed position you can't save a mouse
by like targeting that uh version of the
of the mouse trap it's already done its
job it's already killed the mouse like
so the fusion protein of a lot of these
viruses it's thermodynamically it's
holding a lot of energy it does work and
the um
it likes to end up in the post-fusion
confirmation like after it's done its
job and antibodies against that do
nothing for you they're useless they
bind to parts of the protein that aren't
even like relevant to protecting you
from infection so these guys geniusly
came up with a way to lock it into the
pre-fusion
conformer which
focuses your immune system's attention
on exactly the thing that's going to
block the the rogue virus from getting
into your cell and so i know these
people they're good people that this guy
invented a new version of it that
they're allowing people to use in like
vietnam for like almost no cost like
these people and moderna is not
enforcing their patents right now on
their their mrna vaccine because they're
not like
they really i mean we all are suffering
our economies are suffering because of
the disease so to just like be like oh
well they're making money so it must be
a bad vaccine or they're rushing it
that's not true i mean the fda is not
making a buck or a profit
approving things like inappropriately
and in fact there was a lot of tension
during the last administration because
the um
the people in power and the federal
government were trying to push the fda
to prove things faster or like drugs
like hydroxychloroquine which absolutely
don't work like because they want to
score a political win and and health
should not be political it has to be
based on facts like you don't want to
like lie to people or
help someone get elected by saying oh
we've got the cure you know like there's
a guy jared bolsonaro in in brazil they
have the worst out of control pandemic
basically in the world right now or one
of them um and some of the scariest
variants are emerging from this lack of
control of the virus because every time
you let the virus like infect the new
person and make them sick it's like it's
like buying someone a coin at a slot
machine or giving them a coin like every
once in a while like most of those like
infections aren't going to mutate into
like a scarier virus or one that escapes
antibodies or infects people better but
every once in a while it gets the three
cherries in the slot machine and the
virus comes up with new mutations that
make it a little better at affecting
children which we don't want and
spreading between people silently and
even infecting people who already
recovered from covid so all these issues
are linked vaccines like believing in
vaccines understanding how mass work
like
controlling the pandemic being honest
with people like approving drugs that
actually work and vaccines actually work
like
anyway my message is that the fda
doesn't make a dollar more if by by
approving a vaccine first and they and
that's a separation of power and a good
one i don't believe the government does
everything right i don't believe the
gates found foundation does everything
right in fact i think they they both do
a lot of things wrong but with this with
this vaccines like this set of vaccines
against cover 19 the the fda and the u.s
government and these pharmaceutical
companies moderna biointect pfizer and
johnson and johnson the three that are
approved so far those have all done
amazing transparent work to protect
public health and we should celebrate
that i mean if you get one of those
vaccines you're almost 100 percent uh
impossible for you to die from covid
even if you caught b-117 even if you
caught like the scariest variants we
know of you will not end up with
pneumonia in the hospital you might
still catch the virus a little bit and
you might spread it but and that's why
people of all ages even if you are
younger and like oh it's not going to
make me sick well do you want to be part
of a transmission chain that gets the
virus into a prison full of people who
aren't even there for like like some of
those people in there are innocent
probably they were like sent to prison
or they were there on like a drug charge
or they're just poor and black and
didn't have a good lawyer and these
people don't have a choice to socially
distance and they're at the mercy of
whatever state governor feels and some
people are like oh they're prisoners so
we should vaccinate them last which i
think is really inhumane it's like
that's like a that's like an evil
experiment like if you're if you're
locking people up like if you can't
vaccinate them release them like that's
just inhumane and so do you want to be
part of a transmission chain you go to a
bar you're young you're fine i don't
need it and then you give it to someone
else who gives it to someone else who
gives it to someone else and then that
person's girlfriend works at a prison in
an office and then she's talking to
someone who's award a warden and he
gives it to a guard and then all of a
sudden 600 people in a prison have
coveted because they they don't get to
separate from the person who's their
cell mate they don't get the distance
when they're at the cafeteria and old
folks home like do you want to be part
of a transmission chain that kills
someone's girlfriend or or mother or
gets like one of those rare instances
when a kid gets like multi-system
inflammatory disease or long covid like
we have 25 year old professional
football player athletes or college
athletes who are like done with their
their football career because they're
one of the rare examples of like you
know one in a thousand people in their
20s who
is really really gets ill from it or
doesn't think they got that l but then
all of a sudden like they can't breathe
that well for months and they can't like
run like they used to and that's messed
up i mean why would you want part of
that
yeah yeah okay okay one
that was very interesting
um
that was very hold on let me look at my
list of questions
my concern
with um how kovitt has been treated
is the
lack of statistics behind what happens
when you lock down people
and what the what the side effects are
like i know people who've had serious
surgeries moved in toronto because they
closed down sections of the hospital
they had like cancer patients waiting
for cancer and because we have a free
health care system you can't really pay
a head you have like deadly cancers and
their surgeries are being delayed so my
concern is you know when you
shut down society or slow down society
to focus on one aspect that is
potentially dangerous you ignore all the
other aspects that are potentially
dangerous that might add up to more
dangers that was my concern i totally
agree with you i mean i think there's no
one who's pro-lockdown no one likes no
one likes a lockdown physicians don't
like ontario likes likes a lot the
leadership sees it as necessary and and
if people like i i don't know enough
about specifics on the ground about but
i doubt like anyone's getting rich
locking down
i mean that all the businesses don't
want to lock down the government makes
less tax revenue when they're locked
down but they don't they're they're
probably being very very careful because
maybe they're freaked out about this
variant called b117 which is freaking a
lot of people out because it's so fast
at spreading um and so if people get the
vaccine
and people wear masks and and and like
agree about like hey let's not crowd
indoors then i think the lockdowns
become less necessary i don't i don't
wouldn't want to be a governor
announcing a lockdown i think everyone
can agree lockdowns suck no no one likes
lockdowns i don't think any of the
health leaders like lockdowns i would
just make the argument that the
beginning of the pandemic and when
something feels out of control they tend
to they tend to react in a they try to
react in a way that's going to bring the
case numbers down because that
that draws down transmission and as soon
as you get the case numbers low enough
we can start to be indoors eating
without a mask on
or doing a lot of things that we used to
do before but you know it's like it's
just funny
i mean i don't want to get into politics
and lockdowns because that's that's
hairball like and i think some states in
the united states have been a little bit
overzealous about like mask mandates
like why should you have to wear a mask
if you're like alone on a beach like you
know without 100 people around you for
hundreds of like hundreds and hundreds
of feet and a high breeze like there's
not like you're not going to be
spreading covet we know that like
scientists know that but that's the law
sometimes in certain places and like you
know i don't like you know i like to i
like to follow laws that i agree with
that make sense to me so i think the
challenge is on those leaders to explain
why the lockdown is important and and
what the benefit is to you of like
you know you're a citizen you're
affected by this lockdown you know this
is this is why we're doing it but i'm
not going to try to pitch your lock down
to you i mean it obviously sucks to walk
down
obviously i i think i think part of the
reason there's so much insecurity around
the vaccine is because there are these
mandates where it's like wear a mask on
the beach
uh and people are like well that doesn't
make sense why why should we trust
anything else you say
this is backfiring terribly like i i
know in some countries they were they
did a very strict lockdown maybe for
three months where it was like you're
stuck inside your house in some
countries then they slowly opened up
they had a rise in cases managed to get
vaccines and they and then they opened
up it was this huge spike and then it
was just like you know masks some of
them are masks outside still but they
opened up and with canada and areas of
the u.s it's just gone like this and
people are so freaked out they're like i
don't trust anything you're putting out
there
yeah well that's a hard problem well
they start to trust it again when their
friends get sick i mean like i live in
louisiana there's a pretty conservative
state so a lot of people are skeptical
of the mandates but a lot of my
conservative friends came down with
covet and their attitudes changed about
it after they were kind of freaked out
like but they kind of joke about it
after but they were like wow you know i
was like i was watching my blood oxygen
that i was not freaked out like and
these are people who didn't believe in
masks and stuff and now they kind of
like they still don't like mass and they
still like following the government but
they're like oh they weren't lying like
i was really really sick like that
wasn't fun um so
it's
i just be very careful i think the thing
that we all have a tendency to do as
humans as we get emotional and then we
choose like a side and then like we
agree with everything on that side like
oh everything the government said must
be a lie because they lied once or
someone who worked for but the
government isn't like one thing it's
like it's you and me if we had jobs in
government we'd be government people and
you and me might not agree and one
department might be a little bit corrupt
and shady or have some agenda that
they're not doing well or trying to
protect someone's reputation or or drive
a news story like kind of stuff you
don't want to hear about the people in
the government doing but other another
department might have been like led by a
really good person for years who's
really worried and cares with all their
heart about the health of children and
wants to make sure they have access to
good education and nutrition or whatever
and they've been doing amazing work for
decades so you have to like break it
down and realize like it's not black
versus white there's a lot of gray in
the world like the person telling you
not to trust the government may have an
agenda too they may be trying to sell
you something you should be critical of
everyone and think for yourself and be
an independent thinker if you start to
follow someone with that platform and
agenda like has a big radio show or you
know leads a nutritional supplement
company they may have an agenda too to
make you doubt pharmaceuticals like they
may like all pharmaceutical companies
are not evil like they are businesses
and they do need to like you know stay
in business but a lot of the people
working there are like i know people who
are virologists for years and some of
the smartest ones and got like recruited
to work at pfizer and the the the head
of pfizer right now um in the infectious
disease area is a really good person who
trained with the very best structural
biologists who solve the structure of
the protein on flu virus that lets it
get into cells and that guy's name is
phil dormitor and i've seen his work and
i've seen like at a conference they had
a vaccine against a virus i study called
cmb and it didn't work and he presented
the data and like we tried our best this
didn't work we're getting out of this
like we're not even going to try to do
this anymore other companies can try
that's fine we've got our best shot this
platform is not working for us we have
to be honest about what the data is
saying we've been we've even tried it in
like recess macaques and we're just
going to be transparent and show the
scientific community everything we did
and even though it didn't work and so
you can trust a guy like that when he
shows you data that does work yeah
yeah okay last question uh how do you
feel about people talking about
the role of diet vitamin d exercise
zinc whatever else and uh
this is so funny because it's true on
the one hand if you're malnourished your
immune system's not gonna work as well
that's true
um
however like when i grow virus in the
lab and my grad students are learning
how to grow virus prep like you have to
take care of yourselves and like kind of
like nanny them like nurture them baby
them because viruses like healthy cells
they require your cells and the vitamins
and your cells to copy that they're
pirating yourself they love a healthy
just like a person might if you're a
carnivore might like a juicy steak like
it's going to make you feel robust or if
you're a vegan like have like a really
fresh macrobiotic bowl like the virus
getting into a well-fed healthy person's
cells if it has all the immune evasion
tricks that that stars kobe 2 which is
the virus that causes cope 19 does it
hot wires the cell and it's so stoked
that you ate lots of vitamin d and that
you had a really healthy
diet and like yeah i mean zinc may give
you some tiny protection against cold
but once once the virus gets in your
cells it doesn't zinc is not like a
magical cure-all there's no like
superpower that zinc gives you it's it's
a it's a micro it's a micronutrient it's
a it's a low abundance like metal it is
important as a cofactor for certain
enzymes but the virus has enzymes that
use utilize zinc too to do those
catalytic events to escape your immune
system so that's why viruses often in
history have been harder to treat than
bacteria because they're using your cell
circuits against you they're they are a
rogue genetic code that mostly harnesses
your own machinery they do have a few
enzymes of their own so if you're a
well-fed version and get a path if
you're a well-fed person and you catch
ebola or you catch a really nasty flu
virus or coronavirus or loss of fever
virus you are no better off than
for it like it's not going to be like
your your life is saved from that your
life is going to be saved by having a
good antibody
this is then this is the last question
why is it worse for people with
multiple
problems or obesity and old people
that's a good question and they're still
they're still studying some of those
issues but like for instance diabetics
like have a really high
unregulation dysregulation of blood
sugar so they get like their cat their
their vascular system is already being
kind of stressed and high pressure high
blood pressure is the same this virus
attacks the endothelial cells that lie
in your blood vessels and make and makes
like a
dysregulated inflammatory response so
inflammation we know isn't really
healthy for us and these people who have
high blood pressure or diabetes are
already they're already existing in a
stress like even at baseline before
they're sick their body is fighting just
to like
maintain some level of health that they
can function because some things are
kind of like
not as healthy as they could be about
their like bodies and so the virus just
pushes it pushes that further out of
balance and that's why they're probably
at more risk of severe disease but some
of those molecular mechanisms are still
being very much studied about why those
people get more sick but don't forget
there are people who don't have diabetes
high blood pressure who are like super
good athletes
that we don't know yet why certain ones
get really really deathly ill or even
die and others don't what we do know is
that vaccines protect everyone even
diabetics even like those weird people
we don't understand why they get sick
theoretically though if if eating less
sugar is eating less sugar reduce the
risk of diabetes
um it would reduce the risk of
developing certain types of diabetes
like type 2 diabetes type 1 diabetes is
autoimmune so it's not going to help you
for that
so then theoretically eating less sugar
which would is a component in in certain
diets
would reduce the risk of diabetes which
might decrease the risk of severe
cocaine
yeah i mean being healthy is never a bad
thing but the the message that's being
put out there like hey if you lift a lot
of weights or work out a lot have a
healthy diet you don't have to worry
about covet that is a myth and and the
really irresponsible part of that is
you're amplifying like i am not so
worried about the average 20 year old
dying of covid i am worried about them
getting together spreading the virus
causing the emergence of new variants
that spread even better and then you
know
people don't just hang out with other 20
year olds they even if they pretend they
do they they have parents they uh you
know they work with other people so the
virus moves we've all seen these grass
like the scientists especially there's
an outbreak among 20 year olds and 30
year olds and then
within six weeks there's that outbreak
has moved into the older age populations
who are trying to protect themselves but
you know grand grand grandma still wants
to see your grandkids and the families
get together and i think that those are
the things we want to protect you want
to keep the schools open so why not
close the bars because people in bars
are talking without mass and being loud
and sucks have to close the bar but
maybe just have outdoor bars or
something or like you know figure out
how to like allow people to get together
outdoors in ways that are safe just like
talk about the facts and like make it so
like hey you want to go to a concert go
to outdoor concert like let's try to
figure out or like let's how to work on
ventilation systems to like make it a
little bit safer but you know it's just
like let's just go with science and
reason based things that are like common
sense like you know i don't have to
argue with you about like a sun the sun
if you sit in the sun all day you can
get a sunburn like people believe that
they see it happen um
like we shouldn't have to have this
argument about viruses
like that they can be a threat agreed i
agree okay i'm out of time thank you so
much for coming on um if people want to
find you is there any way to find you
yeah um
i'm on twitter as macro leader which is
m is like just a joke i did because in
in the lab you pipet micro leaders which
means a millionth of a leader so um
that's a place you can follow me and
then i'm jeremy camille k-a-m-i-l
um and if you google me and like virus
you'll probably find
some website
thanks for having me on and i wish
everyone good luck and stay healthy and
get your own information from reputable
sources like don't believe people just
check check it out like like think for
yourselves it's a good thing to do
have fun agree great thank you thank you
bye
[Music]
you